good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric Gershon capuchin monkeys
reveal more about you and all of us than
we might think because we're just not as
different as we might like to think Yale
psychologist Laurie Santos studies
capuchins and other animals to gain
insight into the evolution of the human
mind today she'll talk with us about
some of what she's learned
as always we'll take some of your
questions you can tweet us at Yale or
email us at social media at yale.edu
Laurie thanks for being with us so I
guess my first question and would be why
capuchins yeah so so the main question
we're interested in is what is it that
makes humans tick
why are we so special you know why are
we the only species that are running
Yale live question answer sessions and
no other critter on the planet is doing
this is a really big issue we try to
tackle that question by trying to take
an evolutionary approach to try to turn
to one of our closest living relatives
and ask what do they know about the
world how do they make sense of it and
how does that differ or how is it
similar to some of the ways that humans
do it and you push in monkeys it turns
out our pretty good model for this for
one reason they're one of our close
evolutionary relatives being one other
non-human primate species but another
reason is that as a primate species they
turn out to be pretty good in a couple
of different ways one is that they're
pretty socially sophisticated species
they live in complex social groups turns
out they're really good problem solvers
they actually use tools a lot in the
wild and that makes them a really good
model for studying human cognition in a
lot of ways so we've kind of turned to
them to say okay this is a great primate
model to kind of study how cognition
works in a nonhuman mind and then we can
kind of compare and contrast that with
humans how big are they um they're kind
of you know small dog big cat size okay
and that's that's nice because it makes
them a little bit more convenient to
study than our closest living relatives
say chimpanzees and bonobos we're just
kind of larger and oftentimes a little
bit more dangerous species - mm-hmm now
you focus in a lot of your research on
decision
are we a little bit less evolved than we
might think that is are they making
pretty sophisticated decisions very
similar to the kinds of decisions we
make for better or ill yeah so we got
into this question about decision making
in part because when we started doing
this work it was around the time of the
financial collapse and you saw a lot of
folks on news programs making all these
claims about why we were making such bad
decisions with money and investments and
so on and that got us thinking about
where these kinds of strategies come
from could it be that perhaps some of
the smart things we do with money or
cases where we might see similarities
with capuchins but not just the smart
cases also these cases where we're doing
kind of irrational or Dumber things with
money and so we decided to say wow can
we actually study whether they share
some of the same smart and dumb
strategies that we do the first problem
with this approach though is that of
course these guys don't naturally use
money so we had this methodological
problem of how could we ask them about
their finances and their financial
risk-taking if they don't use something
like a real currency and so teaming up
with an economist Keith Chen and my
student in Venkat Lakshman ri9 we
decided to introduce a novel currency to
this group of capuchin monkeys that we
work with we gave them these little
metal washers that they could use as
their own Capuchin money and we taught
them that they could trade these washers
with humans for food surprisingly they
picked us up much more quickly than we
expected with just a little bit of
they're naturally curious creatures so
they'll kind of pick up these weird
tokens and say kind of what are these
things
and then they quickly realized oh I can
trade this with a human for some
delicious food with just that training
we sort of popped our capuchin monkeys
into their own market so who chained
monkey they live in kind of a big social
enclosure with their their friends when
they get hungry they can kind of tunnel
out to come into the study and when they
arrived there they had a little wallet
of tokens and they could trade not just
with one person but with a bunch of
different people who are selling
different foods at different prices and
we could ask these standard questions
economists ask you know do they capuchin
monkeys care about price do they care
about risk are they kind of maximizing
their Capuchin dollar and in all of
those cases the surprising answer seemed
to be yes they're smart about their own
Capuchin token economy in a lot of the
same ways we are
they pay attention to price they go for
the cheaper option they can kind of
maximize their their wealth level across
these different goods but this the sad
perhaps in certain somewhat surprising
thing was that they also seem to be
irrational about their money in the same
spots that people are irrational
so one thing we found is that the
capuchin monkeys tend to pay too much
attention to loss
this is phenomena that behavioral
economists or loss aversion exactly you
know people are so averse to loss and
that this causes them to do sometimes
crazy things in markets like it causes
human consumers to take on more risk
she'd become more risky when you're you
have this possibility of going into the
red and what we found out was that our
capuchin monkeys in their market did the
same thing they faced an experimenter
who is giving losses they tended to seek
out more risk than they otherwise would
have liked to do how did that manifest
itself in your experiment and then maybe
an example of how that manifests among
humans yeah so in the case of humans I
could give you different scenarios about
choices you could make that have safe
options or risky options so let's say
you're trying to come up with a program
to combat some sort of terrible disease
and I could say well one option would if
there's 600 people whose lives are at
stake
this one would save 200 people for sure
or you'd have a risky program where
sometimes it would save two-thirds of
the time it would save all 600 and
one-third of the time it would save
nobody and the question is what do you
pick and what you find is when you're
framing this in terms of the number of
lives that would be saved people say I
should go with the safe option here and
save as many people for sure as I can
this is shows us that we're kind of
avoiding a risk however if I frame the
same problem in terms of the number of
lives that would be lost this sort of
activates your loss aversion so now for
sure 400 people are gonna die for sure
and one option or in the other case you
know there's a third a chance that you
know everybody will die and a second
chance that nobody will die what you
find is that people tend to gravitate
towards the more risky option in that
case even though the probabilities are
exactly the same across the two and the
idea there is that we're so averse to
losing that we want to go with the
chance that nobody will die even if
overall that forces us to take on more
risk than we would like of course with
the monkeys we can't give them weird
scenarios about how many people are
going to die or live and so what we do
is give them options in their mark
where the monkeys are trading with
people who deliver more or less food
than the monkeys expecting ultimately
they're gonna get the same amount of
food but sometimes they're receiving
more than they expect which feels like
extra feels like you're kind of going
into the black sometimes they're getting
cases where they're receiving less than
they expect and so this feels bad it
feels like they're losing some so some
of what you're doing reminds me a lot of
behavioral economics and I wondered have
you have you been working with Bob
Shiller say oh yeah Daniel Kahneman
maybe a yeah so this work was really
directly inspired by saying let's take
these fantastic cases that Danny
Kahneman and others have used and
translate them into ways we can ask them
one keys in their own market and so
really what we what we quite literally
did was you know grab a famous Kahneman
paper figure out his scenarios and then
say how can we ask that with monkeys and
tokens and when we directly translate
those scenarios into monkey terms we see
not just the same kind of effect that
the monkeys are loss averse and so on
but almost even the same magnitude of an
effect so Kahneman colleagues have
famously found that we emotionally pay
attention to losses about two times more
than we do gains and we see almost
exactly that same magnitude of an effect
in the monkeys - so kind of
qualitatively in in some ways
quantitatively similar performance your
colleague here at Yale Karen Wynn
studies infant cognition have you
noticed any similarities between the way
infants learn and the the capuchin
monkeys live yeah so I mean the project
of studying human infants is
conceptually really similar to their
project of studying monkeys they're both
interested in this question of where
does our cognition come from you know
where did the many smart things that we
do come from and in some cases some of
the Dumber things that we do and one of
the things we've seen when you look
across what's the earliest cognition and
development that would be the case of
babies versus the earliest cognition
over evolution in the case of capuchin
monkeys you see a set of abilities that
seem to be shared across the two so
Karen Wynn has famously done some work
looking at the origins of our numerical
capacities how is it that we learned to
add and subtract and what she's famously
found is that from a very young age
about 6 months it seems like babies can
compute the answers to simple arithmetic
problems
turns out you see the same
and non-human animals and about the
limits that you see babies performing
correctly on these addition and
subtraction tests you see exactly those
same limits in non-human primates too
and so the claim is that in a couple
different domains both in the number
domain and in some cases in the physical
domain
you see these similar capacities and
some similar signature limits across the
infant human infants on the one hand and
non-human primates on the other and the
claim by some researchers has been that
there might be some sort of core
knowledge or core abilities that we all
bring to the table whether you're a
human or a nonhuman primate and that the
key thing about being a human is that
somehow those initial abilities that you
bring to the table through evolution get
built upon they serve as the foundation
for these later things that we learn Oh
perhaps uniquely as our own species
I wanted to ask you about the term
cognition is do psychologists have a
very specific definition in mind when
they talk about cognition as opposed to
the sort of everyday work it's pretty
similar to the everyday use of the word
I mean really what we mean when we think
about cognition is how we represent
information think about it and the
strategies we use to kind of build on in
so the term cognition covers things like
the way we think about the world the way
we use strategies to explain the world
the way we represent the world usually
if I'm talking to a layperson and I'm
talking about the cognitive studies I do
if they're like oh yeah cognition I kind
of get what you mean yeah you do your
studies both in the lab and also in the
wild hmm can you talk a little bit about
the differences in those the experiments
are able to do in the lab versus in the
wild and the differences in what you
learn in one context versus the other
yeah and so so I think of these two
approaches is really complimentary in a
lot of ways take the Capuchin token
studies we did if we were working with
capuchins who were wild living it be
nearly impossible for us to do those
studies right you know they could put
you into arboreal guys so they'd be
aiive off up in the trees really take
the token yeah so there's the cut
there's a kind of methodological
precision that you only get in
laboratory settings however the with
that comes the downside that you're
really limited in some of the kinds of
questions you can ask you're limited in
this sort of ecological validity you
have for exploring these kinds of
because the animals are doing the kinds
of experiments you do but in this very
restricted context by trying to study
cognition both in naturally living
situations and in the lab you kind of
get the best of both worlds and that
sort of that approach that that we've
been trying to do both working with
capuchin monkeys in captivity but also
with free ranging rhesus macaques who
live very naturalistically
we do this at a at an island site in
Puerto Rico known as Cayo Santiago okay
so could you give us an example of the
the kind of experiment just in brief
that you might run in the wild and what
and something that you've learned from
one of those experiments yes so I'll
tell you about the wild version of what
Karen Wynn's been doing say with her
babies so we can ask whether these
free-ranging rhesus macaques understand
something about number using exactly the
same method that Karen Wynn did what she
does is she brings babies into the lab
and she shows them magical events so
she'll show them one Mickey Mouse doll
goes into a box and then the second one
is added into the box
oh well it's covered up and then she can
reveal the number of objects there and
the idea is that if babies know that one
Mickey Mouse plus one Mickey Mouse
equals two they should expect there to
be two and what you find is that they're
surprised and look longer in cases where
there's only one Mickey Mouse so there's
an analysis of the length of time that
they're staring at exactly so she's
videotapes the babies reaction and can
time it later we do this exactly the
same way with our macaques at the field
site it's a little bit different because
we have our little magic stage and we
have to hike around this big island but
we find monkeys who are kind of you know
sort of sitting there bored and asked
them you know would you like a dinner
show with your food that you're eating
and sort of plopped down and do exactly
the same things you can add one eggplant
to a box with a second eggplant and then
reveal different outcomes and what's
been shown at the field site is that in
fact monkeys will react the same way so
they look for a short amount of time
before one eggplant +18 my equals two
and for a much longer time if one
eggplant plus one eggplant equals one or
one I plant plus 1 eggplant equals 3
again suggesting that some very similar
capacities are there and the babies and
the monkeys and the cool thing is that
we can use exactly the same sorts of
experimental methods as we can with the
monkeys as we can with human infants so
it allows for this really precise
comparison across the two groups what
question from viewers this one comes to
us by Twitter from at and 33rd and she
asks whether you believe that animals
have feelings or not mm-hmm
for sure I believe the animals have
feelings I mean I feel like any human
who's watching the animals can't help
but interpret their behavior has built
on different kinds of emotions their
feelings and beliefs and desires and so
on the trick as a scientist is to figure
out how we can determine that for sure
and that gets a little bit trickier
because we have to have methods that can
allow us to measure those things the
method I was just telling you about
where we're showing the monkeys these
events and watching they're looking
tells us something about the monkeys
surprise towards events we think were
their expectations about events directly
measuring the monkeys experiences or
their feelings gets trickier but more
and more researchers are developing some
cool techniques to do that so I
naturally like most humans who watch
these animals have an intuitive fast
belief that they're experiencing the
same kinds of things that I am and I
deeply believe that they do measuring it
is a trickier task and as a scientist to
make strong claims about that this is
one of the things that we need to to
find ways to do what of
I mean human being experience a wide
range of feelings and some of which are
very subtle what are the feelings that
psychologists are initially thinking I
might try to study and measure in
non-human animals yeah well there's been
a lot of work focused on trying to get
at not emotions and not human animals
trying to see if they have the sorts of
basic emotions that we have a lot of
this sort of work analyzes how the
animals communicate about different
emotions and sort of uses their
vocalizations to get a sense of this
stuff but there are some rich questions
about whether animals have other kinds
of more complex emotions things like
guilt things things like schadenfreude
a' is one that's come up in our lab you
know do they like to see bad things
happen - yeah exactly and so so I think
this is going to be the holy grail of
studying animal feelings is to ask this
question whether they have these more
complicated kinds of emotions
humans have ones that we sometimes think
of at least in passing as human unique
mm-hmm
have you found that monkeys clearly
outsmart humans in any way in any
particular task or way yeah so this is a
question we get a lot particularly when
we show all these cases where monkeys
are as irrational as humans people say
are there spots where monkeys are more
rational than humans and so far we found
one spot in the context of the monkey
economy where we see them outsmarting
people and that has to do with how
people react to price so one of the
irrationality is that behavioral
economists look at has to do with these
cases where the price of an object can
affect how much you like it
not because a better higher price object
is actually better but just because the
price itself is affecting your
preference so if in our little water
glasses here we had you know delicious
wine instead of water I could affect how
you subjectively experience that wine
just by telling you is more expensive I
could probably do that with the water -
if I told you it's just tap water it
would taste less good than if I told you
we bought you know very expensive Evian
water this you know fantastic your live
event and there's this fantastic
neuroscience work showing that it's not
just yourself report of how the this
experience is for higher price items you
can actually look using these neuro
scientific techniques at how somebody's
reward area fire is when you're
experienced in this and what you find is
that just by telling you something's
higher priced a wine or a piece of
chocolate or so on you actually
experience it in your very reward areas
as better physiologically
physiologically the same wine will taste
better if I just tell you it's a higher
price than if it's not and so this was
something we wanted to look at in the
monkeys do they like higher priced goods
too and we had this wonderful
opportunity to ask this question because
we showed in our earlier work that the
monkeys really understand price and
their markets they shift correctly based
on the price of a good they they buy
more of the cheaper good they seem to
understand price in the way that an
economist might want them to understand
it and so he said given that they
understand price if we show them some
new food and we tell them it's more
expensive will they get tripped up just
like humans well they like the same good
better when they think it's more
expensive and we did about four or five
studies on this and found that across
the board it seems like the monkeys are
just not
acceptable to this bias they like
different foods depending on their own
personal preferences but telling them a
food is higher price doesn't affect
their preference in some ways the
monkeys seem to be more rational about
price and value than humans do I suppose
that in among humans when something gets
priced higher it's no longer a commodity
right it becomes a status symbol of some
sort so perhaps the monkeys seems are
less susceptible to yeah that kind of
that's one interpretation although that
too is shocking because we know that
they they care a lot about status and
hierarchy in terms of their rank what it
seems like more is that the monkeys
might not be learning their preferences
from other individuals in a lot of the
same ways that humans do and this is one
of the things that that we're really
interested in exploring it in other
species now is this issue of how much do
you learn from other social agents and
this question of the extent to which
humans are unique at picking up our
preferences from others conforming to
others preferences and so on we've
talked a lot about capuchin monkeys are
there other animals that that you study
or that you expect to reveal a lot of
other interesting aspects of the way our
minds are developed yeah and this is a
nice transition sort of based on some of
this work on social learning because one
of the the new animal populations that
were turning to now to look at the speed
in particular that these questions of
social learning are our own pet dogs so
domesticated dogs turn out to be this
fantastic new population that
comparative researchers are turning to
in part because even though they're not
especially close evolutionary relatives
you know we're on the mammal tree with
dogs but they're pretty distantly
related it turns out because dogs grow
up in very human-like environments they
might provide this fantastic window to
ask what the role of those environmental
experiences might be like you know so
your domesticated dog just like a human
child will grow up in a world of human
artifacts they'll be present when
there's this rich human communication
going on and it turns out that through
domestication they also seem to be very
built to pay particular attention to
human cues and the question is given
that there they live in these
environments they're shaped to pick up
on these cues are they learning in some
of the same ways as a human child might
learn and so we are now moving towards
doing more dog cognition work and I'm
happy to announce that we will be
opening yells first canine cognition
second cognitions canine cognition
Center this is not dogs that we have on
premises we actually need your viewers
to help us out because we're hoping that
folks will bring in their companion
animals your your dog can come in for
about an hour half hour and do some
little problem-solving games and that
will teach us of how your dog thinks
about the world are you looking for any
particular kind of dogs or although
we're pretty equal-opportunity one of
the things we're really interested in
looking at is if you see different
cognitive differences across different
breeds hmm and in fact there's some
hints that some of the ways that breeds
have been shaped over evolutionary time
whether you're a breed that shaped to be
cute versus your breed that shaped to
work alongside a human being that might
shape different kinds of cognitive
abilities and so we're expecting to look
for breed differences but as I said
we're really an equal-opportunity canine
cognition Center and we think we have a
lot to learn from all the different
breeds that are out there so are you
shifting somewhat the the focus of your
research to how humans influence
learning among in this case dogs and
then presumably we could extrapolate
somewhat to to you to small children
exactly I think any grownups for that
matter yeah I mean one of the nice
things about about dogs relative to
primates is that they're they're very
built to pay attention to human cues I
mean this is a striking thing when you
work with primates is that they're
willing to to gain information from you
but they're not as much expecting you to
kind of communicate that information to
them so they can have learn from others
but they're not cued into all kinds of
different cues just to give you one
example with our capuchin monkeys even
though these guys are really motivated
to find food and so on they do really
bad in a test where say you're a
capuchin monkey and I've hidden some
food and I'm pointing and looking at one
location they can't figure out that I'm
trying to communicate information to you
with my gaze and my pointing about where
the food is you do exactly that same
test with a with a dog and they'll
immediately pick it up on the
trial they get that you that humans
often try to communicate with them that
there's this give-and-take about
learning and they're very cute into the
particular kinds of cues that humans use
such as I gaze and pointing and so on
and so when our question is about how do
individuals learn from each other some
ways primates are not as good of a model
in some ways as dogs might be and so
this is what we're hoping to do in the
new canine cognition centers to start
studying these questions about social
learning to compare how dogs make sense
of the world using human cues and
compare and contrast that with what a
human child might do in the same
situation do you have any sense of how
many dogs you would need to do sort of a
scientifically meaningful study mm-hmm
so there's been lots of dog cognition
studies out there usually the sample
sizes are on the order of about you know
between 20 and 50 dogs depending on how
big the size of the effect is the goal
for us is the more the more dogs we can
test the more we can learn about these
subtle breed differences and the more we
can make comparisons not just dogs
versus humans or dogs versus primates
but within the class of dogs which
breeds are doing what and who
specialized for what dogs of course I've
often been referred to as man's best
friend and we perceive them many of them
as very loyal is there any is there any
scientific reason to believe that the
desire to be liked or a capacity for
empathy mmm-hmm makes a person better at
learning yeah it's a good question I
mean I think the our degree of being
able to kind of automatically pick up on
other people's cues seems to for sure
help learning in the case of animals
what we know is that you're you're very
tolerance around being around other
individuals can affect the degree to
which you can learn particularly from
some of these cues that I was just
telling you about and there's been this
fantastic case trying to test this
particularly trying to test this
question about how much you you get in
terms of social learning through
domestication and it happened not in the
case of domesticated dogs but in this
case it's a novel case of domesticated
foxes so over the past few decades in
Russia there's been a team of scientists
who've been asking this question what
does it take to domesticate an animal
and they've chosen to do this with wild
foxes they've been doing this over foxes
are very close to dogs aren't they yeah
I mean over it but but not domesticated
wow these guys and so what the scientist
did was just to bring a group of wild
foxes in and they picked the ones to
breed just based on how close they got
to the people so in a big pan of foxes
whoever got closest to the human
experimenters is like all right you guys
are the domesticated group will breed
you guys and the other guys which what
the scientists refer to as the wild type
and the question is what they just did
this over and over generations what they
found though was that in addition to
breeding and more tolerance around
people they also got all these other
traits in for free so the domesticated
foxes have floppy ears just like
domesticated dogs they have what's
called piebald coats which is a sort of
coat color that's often has these little
white patches just like not only
domesticated dogs but domesticated cows
and horses and so on interestingly you
get smaller brain size relative to body
and you also get lower cortisol levels
so lower stress hormones the amazing
things even though they were just
picking based on who got closer to
humans you got all this other stuff for
free and another canine cognition
researcher by the name of Brian hare has
done some cognition studies on these
domesticated foxes versus the wild the
wild type ones and what he finds is that
these domesticated foxes are also better
at learning from these human cues than
the wild type foxes so even though these
foxes weren't weren't domesticated for
that he weren't being bred to pay
attention to these cues specifically
something about the domestication
process allowed the foxes to pick up on
these cues better than their wild-type
colleagues and I think this is a lovely
example of this case that just being the
kind of critter who's comfortable around
other social agents can allow you to be
around them enough to pick up on these
cues that might really help you learn
about the social world
you mentioned cortisol and stress I'm
going to take a question from Sheila who
emailed us and her question is since
animals and humans both experience
stress and respond to it what can we
learn from animal behavior about ways to
modify our response so we can so we can
not make stressful situations worse
mm-hmm I mean I think this is one of the
the big topics that folks who study the
biology of stress are doing is to try to
figure out animal models for some of
these kinds of things you know as for
what answers we've gotten so far I'm not
sure we've gotten some some clear
answers from other animals just yet I
mean one of the things that we we've
learned and that we've been studying at
the field site is that there seem to be
really interesting individual
differences in in individuals responses
to stress you see this a lot in the
context of the field site where you see
animals at different spots of the
hierarchy reacting completely
differently to stressful situations and
we can use some of these individual
differences to try to gain insight into
some of the mechanisms that underlie
stressful responses and hopefully some
of this work will tell us something
about what we can do better another
question this one from Mike h also by
email is jealousy inherent in humans or
is it a learned trait and is there
anything we can learn from primates and
dogs about a complex human emotion like
jealousy great question it turns out
that there's actually some cool research
on this very question both in capuchin
monkeys and in dogs and this is about
jealousy of a particular form cases
where you are jealous because another
individual has something that's better
than then you have and how do you react
to that so there's a famous experiment
with capuchins by Sarah Brosnan and
Fran's de Waal and their colleagues
where they set subject capuchin monkeys
up with a situation in which they might
be jealous so they're doing this trading
task that I've just described they're
trading with an experimenter and the
subject monkeys getting only cucumbers
but the experimenter is varied what the
other guy's got so in one case the other
monkeys that they're watching play this
task two are getting cucumbers that's
fine they react totally fine to that the
question is what happens when the other
monkeys they see trading are getting
something better so other monkeys are
getting a grape which in computing world
is like the most delicious food ever and
what they find is that the subject
monkeys who are trading and just get the
cucumber they stop trading for the
cucumber they either reject the cucumber
when they get it so they just throw it
on the floor this food that they
otherwise liked now that somebody else
is getting something better they just
throw the food on the floor or they
refuse to trade and some some ways this
is this is a result that's been heralded
as monkeys demanding equal pay for equal
so these are there are hints that the
animals are feeling something like
jealousy when they when they're
experiencing these effects it's still
tricky for us to measure whether it's
jealousy per se but at least other
animals seem to be reacting not on the
basis of what they themselves are
absolutely getting but what they're
getting relative to what somebody else
is getting there are hints that dogs may
be showing similar effects so fredericka
Rangga and colleagues have done similar
types of studies with with dogs in this
case dogs are doing some behavior
they're giving paw and they're getting
rewarded for giving paw and the subject
dog in question is giving pawed he's not
getting any rewards and he's watching
another dog his kind of sibling dog from
his house do the same thing and he's
getting rewarded for what he does and
what you find is that the subject dogs
when when they're not getting rewarded
and nobody's getting rewarded it's fine
but when they're not getting rewarded
and somebody else is they stop giving
paw they stop wanting to play and so on
so there are hints that other animals
are reacting on the basis of what others
get whether that's something akin to
jealousy as we as we know about it in
the human species is a tricky question
so based on the entire body of your work
so far what are what are some of the
most deeply rooted cognitive habits
whether they're good ones or bad ones
that human beings seem to seem to have
yeah so we see rudiments of some kinds
of cognitive strategies across different
domains of knowledge so I talked about
one which is this idea that we seem to
have some really early core principles
for thinking about small numbers of
objects out there turns out we have
similarly deeply rooted capacities for
thinking about simple physical intuition
so it seems like we know things about
how objects move in space and the
objects won't move through one another
for example we also seem to have pretty
deeply rooted intuitions about what it
means to be in the social world so we
seem to kind of automatically know that
some individuals have minds and are
alive and are social creatures versus
some individuals are like couches and
tables and there's a big divide between
the two of those it turns out that all
of those intuitions seem to emerge
really early in human development in the
sorts of experiments that Karen Wynn and
others do and all of those same
intuitions seem to be present in
non-human primates - so there seem to be
a set of rich things that are kind of
these core capacities that are there
early on in life in terms of some of the
the Dumber strategies I think one of the
ones that we've seen robustly and other
animals is this idea that we seem to
think about our choices relative to what
others are getting we're relative to
what we expected what we were going to
get before and this is pretty powerful
because it suggests that our decisions
aren't based on so I'm getting some
absolute amount of food or some absolute
amount of wealth or something absolute
all of our decisions are based on this
relative framing you know if we see
somebody else getting more then that
affects what we think we get ourself if
we expected to get more we expected to
get less that changes how we evaluate
things and this seems to be a pretty
deep-rooted strategy that we see both
across our economic studies and across
some of these social studies as well you
spend so much time thinking and studying
how learning general do you find that
you are consciously changing the way
that you think as you learn about some
of the the less rational and silly ways
that human beings in general yeah it
definitely changes the way you think
about things yourself I mean this I just
give one personal example so we starting
to do these studies on kind of risk and
loss aversion and seeing how salient
these kinds of biases were in the
monkeys and this was around the same
time that I was sort of setting up my
benefits I counted yeah you know or they
give you this sort of quiz about you
know what are your preferences and I
sort of started taking the quiz and I'm
you know thinking goodbye rationality
head of like you know I just want to
maximize expected value you know the
heck with loss aversion and so on and I
did my preferences and I came out you
know extremely risk seeking and they you
know the guys in the Benefits Office
really I don't know no one comes out
this high it I was like oh no this is
gonna be terrible like and so I think
that it's a silly story but it reflects
something deep which is that these
aren't necessarily preferences or
intuitions you can overcome very easily
so just knowing that I have them doesn't
make it any less salient so I might
realize that loss aversion may or may
not be a rational strategy but realizing
that doesn't stop me from experience
and I think that's the puzzle of a lot
of what we're learning about the kinds
of intuitions we see shared across other
primates is that some of these things
might be somewhat tricky to just turn
off by just sort of thinking like oh
that's a silly thing to do I should just
shut it off the kinds of intuitions
we're studying don't often work like
that and I think this is the challenge
of understanding them better is that we
might understand that we have these
automatic and tuitions these evolved
strategies for dealing with the world
but just recognizing them doesn't mean
they're gonna be that quick to go away
and that's a challenge for setting up
policies that kind of circumvent these
things are kind of go around them even
though they're not gonna overcome these
strategies necessarily but you might be
able to kind of work with them rather
than work against them switching from
research to teaching for a minute you
teach one of the very most popular
classes at Yale sex evolution and human
nature just briefly describe the class
and give us some of your thoughts about
why you think it's so popular
leaving aside how good you are as a
teacher course and and and some of the
obvious reasons why yeah people in the
early 20s might be interested in course
on sex well yeah I mean I think that
might really be the cause so popular is
because it has sex kind of glaringly in
the title if it was just evolution and
human nature that enrollments might Hank
terribly but it up but the goal of the
class is really to deal with this puzzle
of what is it that makes humans special
I mean we're such a fantastically reared
interesting complicated annoying species
and I think you know every undergraduate
and maybe every human wants to
understand how what makes us tick why
are we the way we are and the the logic
of the class is that one way to get at
this really deep puzzling question is to
take in evolutionary lens that if we
really want to understand what makes
humans special we need to understand
where we came from over evolutionary
time and so the class starts with a kind
of evolutionary look and how first of
all how evolution works and how the
evolutionary process works and that's
when we get to sex because what we
quickly realize is that because we as
humans are sexual reproducers the sexual
process in sexual evolution has very
likely shaped the way that our species
works and so we kind of go through what
it means to be
producer what are the different meeting
systems we see in the animal kingdom
we've kind of covered all these
principles generally and then we try to
apply them to the human species and the
frustrating thing I think my students
experienced in the course is sometimes
we're left with these big open
scientific questions where we have
better answers about what the meeting
species with what the mating system is
of a species like the buff breasted Sam
Piper or a lot because it's observing
exactly and it just gives really tricky
to ask the same questions with humans
it's just much harder to run the studies
there's a famous study on fruit fly meat
choice about how the number of meats you
have affects your reproductive success
and we can do that with fruit flies
because we can just of course library we
can't do that in the same way with
humans and the class ends up involving a
lot of speculation by kind of pushing
the boundaries of what can we really
learn through taking an evolutionary
approach about our own species so I
think that's part of the reason why the
students the student is like it is it's
about this fundamental question that we
all we all want to know the answer to
and and I think the evolutionary
approach is a good way to get it do you
also offer that as a sort of MOOC style
course or through open Yale courses yeah
it's not an open Yale but what we do do
to offer we offer it as part of the Yale
summer session okay and so any of your
viewers who want to be part of the Yale
summer session course who want to take
that course have an opportunity to
enroll in it through Yale summer session
you got to apply to yell summer session
but assuming you hadn't and it's offered
as an online course right now the hope
is that I will soon be adapting that
course for something like a Coursera
style course but that's in the kind of
the two or three year plan but folks who
really want to check out the course can
enroll in that course over the Yale
summer session it's it's in some ways an
even more fun version of the course I
teach live the course I teach live is
several hundred students you know I'm
kind of up there lecturing but I don't
often as much get a chance to get to
know my students directly the online
course is about 15 people so it really
allows for a lot more in-depth
discussion and I get to know the
students better I've done it for the
past two years and it's been really a
fun pedagogical experience so all your
here should jump in and take it we're
running out of time here but I did want
to ask you how should people who are
interested in
they're dogs too you get in touch what
definitely so the best way to get in
touch right now is to drop us an email
our email is canine dot cognition at
Yale ddu canine cognition at Yale D and
just drop us a line and tell us about
your dog what we'll do is we'll e-mail
you back with a link to our survey
you'll go online and tell us a little
bit about your dog and we'll be able to
kind of schedule you up to get going and
bring your dog in so we can learn
something about their psychology our
grand opening for the canine cognition
Center is December 2nd we're gonna have
a big opening ceremony but if you're
excited to get involved sooner we
definitely would love your information
sooner rather than later
so that's canine cognition at Yale DT is
Laurie Santos thank you so much for
being with us today thanks to all of you
for watching and I hope you join us
again next time
you